speaking of the Sun someone just
brighten everyone's day of Sam Son of
Sam get it
Oh David Berkowitz yeah don't you hear
but I talk hi everyone hi I talk to
briefly about we were on your show
yesterday when that newscaster that
newscaster when he picked the date in
2017 it was just weird
it was weird right it was some kind of
1979 yeah you think Sarah Jessica Parker
would be better prepared for an event
like this if that guy knew it was coming
you think she was not she's dead paired
like this is like she thought it was
magic in the sky that was happening she
was like this is this is impossible
what's going on you could have made her
like one of your subjects you know like
when people go I will make the Sun go
away if you do not obey me and then they
freak out and then all the sudden comes
back and you go yeah so I cannot do this
again by the way or you shall surely
perish you could have just gone up to
Sarah Jessica Parker and taken personal
responsibility for the Eclipse yeah yeah
she had no idea like what be like David
Blaine right walk up to go watch this
like it's Street magic yeah the Sun
disappears that she freaks out was there
more video there's a second video she
put out she didn't handle it well what a
great long con that would be to have you
found out in 79 and you just started
prepping Sarah Jessica Parker yes nine
time just wait you just wait on this day
at this time be on this boat you'll see
my infinite power did someone come her
down by putting an apple flat in their
hand having her eat it just gave her a
big thing of salt yeah
salt like her sugar cubes she likes
[Laughter]
clips come and started kicking everybody
up the bum look big that guy from 17 I
know when he said he goes I hope the
moon's shadow is cast on a peaceful
earth and I'm just like Oh
so boy do you have it wrong way off yeah
yeah it's much much worse was he miss
Grenada
he missed 911 oh yeah whole Iraq to Iraq
war yeah multiple wars Afghanistan war
that's still going on yeah 9/11 yeah
missed all that stuff he didn't know
what was he to know yeah he probably
figured 2017 flying cars maybe he's a
cool stuff they didn't even have mass
shootings really yet no not many no it
was a daily thing or a weekly thing back
then yeah I don't I up on the Texas
tower yeah back in the sixties yeah she
what was his name by I don't know
Whitmore Charles Whitmore Charles
Whitmore outstanding I saw a documentary
on that guy it was very interesting to
watch yeah how differently things were
handled the 60s because the technology
was there to spot thing and like for in
three hours
yeah we're to out he was up there just
taking shots at people he's picking
people off as like cops walked up with
snub-nosed revolvers and a shotgun they
got from some guy yeah civilians were
pointing rifles up just regular people
yeah they started taking shots at the
cops after they killed him and they're
like peeking over the wall like trying
to go hey we got him and then there's
these Texans going I say this what are
you doing yeah they had no idea where he
was for a while people just dropping and
and they finally went up there's some
cop and some other guy with him just
some guy dude who helped him it wasn't
even two cops was a guy in a cop yeah
that went up and killed him you know man
but yeah you hear the other say I do
yeah Marines outstanding
we made besides
Matthew yes exactly it's so sweet Faris
yeah okay that's right it's totally chip
yeah you know people who react like that
to that like it's so humbling humbling
are probably people that are not humbled
that off right oh right you know like
they're they're just a little bit like
apart from the rest of the world but
this is like this moment where we really
we are one is it look at the Sun right
now it's pretty damn humbling when he's
not on it right
giant fireball in the sky that keeps us
alive nah it's crazy yeah it's warm out
is that that thing hey it's also we can
see yeah that thing what do you think
the view is like yen is people who are
in planes I wonder if the airlines
handed out certain glasses for people on
planes who are gonna have that view or
no they must've yeah these days yeah not
one helpful person without me creeps
[Laughter]
please I'd ask to just buy his seat so I
can put my feet screw him he's trying to
get he's trying to look at an eclipse
and they just smash his face into the
hand right yeah [__] him in the Sarah
Jessica Parker he wrote in on WoW is
that footage from a plane that's [__]
amazing
pretty cool that gets really pitch black
damn yeah it's dark but I mean like this
clouds there oh [__] yeah that's pretty
intense that gets in credit gets dark
very fast and then all of a sudden all
your going so fast that's okay that's
part of this motion heck yeah
well is that fast motion that looked to
be fast motion yeah well is that just
the way the plane would see it no it's
still pretty fast how stupid am I like a
spaceship I just thought the plane flew
by it could have flown out of that or
that view if it's super hot I would have
to be real yeah did did you already like
play Bonnie Tyler not you did not know
but I know I'll tell you this one has
been stuck I'm in my head yeah not was
uh was the one but not total eclipse of
the heart heartache since the moment we
walked out of this studio yesterday
really it has been ringing in my head
jim has been talking like Bonnie Tyler
has re-entered the I am so hot here it's
a heartache because Jim for like ever
since this story first came out that she
was gonna be on a ship yeah Jim has been
defending 2017 Bonnie Tyler yes like no
I so I feel like it I still think it's
good they must have tucked her back away
now she's done nothing 38 years or
whatever I can't not all day yeah and by
the way Travis don't don't instead of
heartache don't start thinking Pekka
because that gets very addicted
[Laughter]
literally
I did Ari Shaffir show last night I mean
I'm upset the Village Underground
watching the video of this from the
South I'm out of my mind when you're
sorry it was it couldn't leave my head
was it from back then or now this
version yeah because she should sing her
ass off here well yeah she was there she
could sing them now she's young
like snapping his fingers [__] I'm
saying it's bad oh you something I
appreciate on the same level as you
oh my like no one was thinking about
this song though you're right I know
let's get to the new version of that one
what do you have yet oh this was good I
did see this she was really good she was
on the boat
God really look at her shoes we did the
interview that she did with CNN I mean
well yeah I actually watched the whole
clip from the boat I watched it last
night and yeah you know she's up she's
getting up there man her voice is her
voice has got a tone now more like when
Lucy used to go on Carson what he would
do
yeah it's not it's not sexy you know
it's not at all cancerous should be
retiring from Yankee Stadium but I do
enjoy I I give a lot of leeway to the
older singer I don't - you do I don't
mind it well that's the thing about the
rasp though she'd think she can get away
with a lot more than she can she thinks
that the rasp of 2017 is still that rest
because everybody talking about a raspy
voice in the 70 Rod Stewart yeah but
this isn't that they called her the
female Rod Stewart they said let's come
in on the on the on the Eclipse boat
with Joe Jonas is banned and it's yeah
they were on the what Oasis no of the
Seas I don't know that was a Royal
Caribbean Libyan one of the big ones -
she was its it wasn't a a half-assed
little boat well they denied the pair a
lot of money to get her there do they
ever had the books yeah do any of these
boats - any of these boats would not
leave from the US well I'm going to
leave from where I put a Rico or other
place where's the Iraq with these crews
that is true he's the cruise mustard
he's the guy they tell him when he's got
to go to the other side of the boat when
they load car
[Laughter]
my god
did he ever jump up in the bottom of the
boat and almost knocked Charles Grodin
into the race
[Music]
there's gotta be better audio better
video than this that's the one I think
my Rolling Stone that's the only one I
saw the pilot yes yes and she does all
kinds of weird like operatic theatrical
stuff yeah actually she's like divine
like put the mic down to the people to
do them what you're doing heartbreak
yesterday and that's what she was doing
there saying no things I hate more when
a singer has to [__] put that mic out
and not not sing the goddamn song which
was at the same video it's the same
video but there's one from like a little
further way and it's the whole song and
stuff she she'd actually do the whole
song did she I think she did she must
have started like a silly minute
reaction yeah 2:40 really I saw because
it was only supposed to cover
yeah the clips the Royal Caribbean blog
posted a video that's 2 minutes and 20
seconds
man shoot if she was on Jimmy's playing
there I thought was just moving quickly
I'm just an eager boy who marveled by
the Sun there it is a nice big ship that
is a big boat man what a good view they
had oh and there's the
who's that guy that's Joe Jonas what is
he what is he looks like Freddie Mercury
like Freddie Mercury right trying to
steal that gig from the other fruit
that's singing that Adam Lambert yeah
look at her giant old lady tits
wow what a [__] boat yeah that's
crazy look at that it's a building on
the sea
I think big boat yeah tell you this
about Joe Jonas he's a considerably
better singer than Bonnie Tyler at this
will guitar players she's kind of cute
that's her that's a Joe Jonas bands bass
player yeah I want to go on a cruise and
gave it to the audience because she was
like totally that is worse than like
Betty Davis eyes ever got you know Oh
would Kim Carnes [__] that up as she got
older in car yeah but then she you know
had the decency to die she dead yeah
good for her III didn't think this was
that bad it's terrible no it's not she's
not really bad no here's what happens
when people are singers and they can no
longer sing anymore they should stop
singing and find a new business dude how
much fun does that boat look like come
on or giant tits look like yeah I
wouldn't mind suckling them in the
[__] captain's cabin yeah keep
listening on the ship
[Music]
that's the Big Rock Climbing Walls
behind her and stuff no she's not so bad
it's so but so did you did you watch the
CNN interview while sure where she was
on the rail of the boat yeah talking
yeah yeah I did see that one did you Jim
I saw something I thought it was
charming are you how I would have loved
his behind her see the bubbles of those
Japanese torpedoes so then she I think
this is either before or after the
Eclipse before yesterday on the ship CNN
had a live feed and they interviewed her
yeah this is great
and they smash it not just a hit it says
Bonnie Tyler does sing smash that was a
big song that was a biggie you are right
she sounds great
she doesn't sound like that anymore or
look like that but she's an older lady
she should stop doing this back
[Music]
yeah that's that's her then a truly
amazing thing is happening on board
truly aging musician is singing on a
cruise ship
well you never see that in other news a
clean comic bombed the Sun she's English
well like Tom Jones so I'm on this
amazing ship and so every time there is
a total solar eclipse your phone rings
off the hook you're you're you take her
for ballast chief your YouTube video
gets thousands of hits whenever there's
a total of gland eclipse
I've got 38 years you get one shut up
guy that's that's terrible observation
there wasn't YouTube in this other song
right you're still singing it's a
heartache that one no I do I do actually
remember that big fan I'm gonna write a
song called quarter moon so every month
I am not sure not just every 38 years
yeah be happy to perform with any other
young bands on cruise ships what a lousy
moment for the interview this is yeah
this is a lousy energy sobani every
several decades you become relevant
again what's that like they are in the
Bermuda Triangle I think is that right
where they they were just off of South
Carolina so right if they died that
would have been great Oh terrific
that big close
counter ship just scoops or rather they
go to take off and then they come back
down and just kick her out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you are the karaoke expert I am I
believe as far as girls are concerned
yeah the number one song is probably I
will survive that's a finger karaoke
sorry yeah that one girls just love that
one go out that go well cap the door and
they [__] you know empowers them and
[__] I think they all get drunk and
probably think they have meaning in this
song totally look at their dumb
boyfriend's face all tenderly drinking
of Schlitz and [__] their sister that
journey song is definitely a very
karaoke which one the one from Sopranos
yeah don't stop believin you're not even
that best song I prefer wheel in the sky
if you want the truth I like lights I
don't think I understand I wasn't
bringing up the topic of everybody your
favorite journey saw everybody funny
topic sure think about it I talked about
it for a minute so many hits yeah Bonnie
Tyler just says and she had the biggest
karaoke song she did but how about oh
top 5 of all time honey in Rhapsody Wow
cut tub-thumping
it a drink drink I'm like here I go
again you don't know how would feel I
don't know how accurate this is I don't
either
it's a [__] out of here how about yeah
try another one will preference I got my
journey song right though Billy Billy no
II not Billy gene is a popular one
Weezer
I'm glad I don't know the answer this
yeah what I'll tell you what as mains of
Leon's what is nice none of the list so
far it's total eclipse of the heart
none of the list
go back go back I say wanna look like a
creep Oh
oh good let's let's [__] go get a bomb
outside you can sing it it's gonna be a
huge hit oh no it's not affected [__]
version he did oh my god were you
performing next the dumpster on 51st was
at the end of the interview there was a
little more but but we have done a
little bit of research and found that
she is incorrect foolish and she does
not have the number one camera now and
this really is only appropriate once
every 38 years unless it's the movie old
school and there's a lot of curses put
into it for me I do enjoy the song
though I will say it's not my iPod
not even my ELLs I bet it's not the
number one song a bit like Tom Jones
yeah has the number one karaoke song in
Wales exactly what's the song called hey
Jay Jonah where's that get out live
where's the exit
what is the Jonah Brothers have to do
with it - a who's guy with the well
Jonah the well [__] in its totality
later on in the afternoon how do you
think a total eclipse of the heart
differs from a total eclipse of the Sun
oh my god he's awful he just actually
said I am officially completely out of
question yeah Wow is that how did how do
they differ what do you do it that
question if you're her the only response
is that has to be the stupidest goddamn
question I've ever heard I would give
him a literal answer but one is a song
and what is this celestial event yes
yeah you [__]
[Laughter]
oh my god is that bad question yeah
she'll laugh right no she was heartbreak
it just shows us that you know this
universe is amazing she's really making
chicken salad right now yeah yes not her
fault this question no not her fault she
should be in the rock what's out there
can you no no no I'm sure not he won't
say can you stare into a total eclipse
of the heart he will not say that
because to say that Jim would put him in
a category of complete and utter buffoon
he would sound like a real [__] if he
said that yes can you stare into a total
eclipse of the heart oh my it's it's
it's pure buffoonery be wearing my
glasses later but I'm sure your bifocals
listen to my heart I wear it on my
sleeve she's doing okay with these
terrible [__] question horrible but
to be fair whoever booked this interview
by this news anchors a Shep Smith would
not put up with this interview he barely
put on the bring me on so he would not
put up with this chef Smith it made a
joke out of the whole thing he thought
it was stupid he did yeah he would never
gimmick now his gimmick is to [__] with
the news and make it seem like I'm much
too important to even deal with this
right like this car this even if it is
important but the Eclipse he was just
goofing on all the reporters that they
had located all over the United States
and everything so I wouldn't mind if you
think I can at least ask her there's
there's plenty of questions to ask her
yeah that are there are an amazing
question but they weren't do she I have
to tell you haribol there is literally
nothing newsworthy about Bonnie Tyler
Wow she did sing on the boat though yes
are you singing on that boat
yo thank you well let good luck yet see
her how he gets out of this one I bet
there uh but there is one good question
to you I I don't even know I have not
seen the end of this interview are you
serious I'm wondering if there'll be a
boat or an eclipse pun so you do you
literally don't know what's going what
happens at the end of this no nothing
bad it's just it's a good question was
the smokestack fall on earth awesome the
ship cracks and half sinks no Jack and
Rose have sex in her she's like a little
chubby car you do in this song the
original song is what like 8 minutes
long you've got to cut it down because
the actual totality of the solar eclipse
is about two and a half minutes right
that's right the total eclipse is like
two minutes forty seconds my song is
like eight minutes except it's had to be
edited but we are doing the full version
today with DNC and doesn't DNC when I
clean out your vagina what's your
favorite line can you give us your
favorite verse from the song okay pause
do you think you have not seen this oh
no what do you think Bonnie Tyler is
gonna do in response to that question
she's probably gonna say like I don't I
don't know I love the whole song have
you seen the end of this no I think we
are gonna hear the most crackly
rendition of the title lyric from the
song deep total eclipse of the heart do
you think Bonnie Tyler is so not
self-aware that she would think that
singing any of that song acapella
acapella television is a good idea for
oh my god look behind her you could see
the fish dying with Sonic [__]
[Laughter]
more than we could ever know she sounds
like Katharine Hepburn oh my god you see
this CNN got Hampton turns the boat he
thinks that was a horn CNN guy put his
lighter eyes lighter was up oh my god
oh why would she do that to herself that
was really bad she knew it too
of course yeah she does all those
dramatic moves like it's three o'clock
in the afternoon but I felt bad for
Bonnie Tyler just an older heavy
someone's grandma she's a nice lady
heavyset she's put a few on oh my god
don't get it look at that getup she's
wearing she does have a pair of fat
Welsh tips the top has a net on it looks
like two beluga whale heads like a
Greenpeace is trying to free those tips
would you suck her tits oh yeah she has
a plague of frogs in her throat it's
just an invasion a biblical invasion of
how it spits what's that one [__]
pepper a little right-wing bene Barney
Tyler you have you have given us more
than we could
ever have hope for thank you so much for
being with us and we wish you luck today
break a leg enjoy a boat total eclipse
of the Sun but more importantly the
total eclipse of the heart Thank You
[__] on is he's terrible got it it's
the same thing
I understood got it you think after he's
gonna get coffee at CNN and they're all
just like dude that [__] Bonnie Tyler
interview you knocked it out of the park
yeah that was funny question asked her
you know the lighter dude really yeah
like how did you think of that sometimes
there is room for a little personality
in the news and you're proving it oh
yeah yeah proving it you're the guy yeah
even back then she was not particularly
hot they're funny enough that's such an
a go to the top right that picture right
there
how 80s is that with this no no go down
a little bit right there to all the way
to the right yeah look at how 80s that
[__] doing oh my god with the open
sports could make the open tie in the
sports coat yeah like the poodle haircut
yeah that's terrible
she dressed dressed like Rick
Springfield yeah and he would wear
that's like what Seinfeld used to do
comedy in yeah that suit it's not good
is that why she was always a little
chunky yeah she's a little chubby but
not in a bad way no that's [__]
whatever she actually for her age and
stuff she's not right yeah that's battle
broad could be worse
well yeah but she sees Jesus on stage
performing reminding people of what she
used to do but that's every older singer
though it's kind of hard to keep the
pipes then knock it off no I still like
seeing them other things to do for money
she had that voice that just had like a
half life to it you know you can't
expect to have that voice right that's
scratchy voice yeah yeah yeah that's
gonna go south real fast and really bad
you think that would hold up though cuz
it's scratchy so it doesn't have to be
similar gets even more six all the
cruise ship gas surprised being polite
about it like oh yeah just waiting for
somebody else to say that was terrible
so they could agree yeah that ship is
all I'm thinking
I want to go is that a good overall
Cribbins are going that I want to go is
that the best one that yeah the Oasis
and the allure are they were Caribbean
lines are different with a different
branch same line yeah that's that's an
even I want and that one I was just on
the allure which is the same class ship
it's like the sister ship it's that big
is the same one yeah it's [__] insane
how are the sweets they're [__] tasty
[Music]
yeah it's the sweet was amazing how long
did you go for can actually see my sweet
from that picture it's on that platform
part on the top of the boat all the way
to the left right there how ironic
Wow is that what you're on that you're
the top right yeah yeah right up there
Wow was able to overlook the people
doing the surfing on the the wave thing
in the back of the pool and and a mini
golf course pay for something he doesn't
give how long do you have to be on the
boat for well it was a week-long cruise
and you stopped at a couple of places
mornin stuff now this [__] giant ship
this stuff to do as a karaoke bar on the
goddamn ball sing nothing but a
heartache and [__] total eclipse of
the heart and a guy like you doesn't get
out to karaoke too often true it was
like taking my basement to a boat that's
exactly what it was let me ask you show
that picture in Troy Sam's boat vans
boat perfect the world right this one
right here
we're being boarded gently booked a trip
to the Rosie O'Donnell cruise Oh with
that big I went to our hobnob with Rosie
we have some more celebrity friends
that's right
what are these two things up there they
look like tits on the top of the ship
what are those for the smokestack so
your yeah your exhaust for all of your
various generators and whatnot they
don't actually have like the old days
where they had giant engines that turn
the propellers
at the engines turn generators
and electricity drives the [__] boat
so electricity drives the board chief
when you're on top there you can see
everything and you have your own what's
in your room yeah I want to I want to be
in a room like great it was two floors
so there was a the bedroom was upstairs
and then the downstairs was the living
room a little kitchen and the big deck
out back you're not spending a lot of
time in the room but it was a big
[__] room but you know your own
private deck oh yeah and and just a huge
a huge deck and it was so nice they
smooth I mean and yeah yeah they got
stabilizers on those things now you
don't feel like god damn thing I love
that your vacation Jimmy now vacated Jim
is all about I'm leaving by the way I'm
leaving Friday right after the show I'm
bringing my I'm bringing my [__]
thanks dude yeah really cool I'm
bringing my suitcase that's so [__]
cool you hear that in there
[__] loaf he doesn't care he does know
I'm bringing my suitcase but yeah I know
a station Jimmy wait you know what Jim
did on last week he goes maybe we'll all
get together at my house to watch the
Conor McGregor Floyd Mayweather and then
yesterday he goes you know I might want
to leave for vacation Wow
sorry guys and he couldn't be less sorry
you sorry Troy hell no I would like to
give you an invitation because at my
house
I am having to fight and a poker game
and a party so you are all thank you
that would have been fun I would love to
have dollars rather than people in my
house I've been at your house in two
years that should be a fun yeah that
should be a fun [__] night yeah and
that fight is good what do you think
it's gonna be Mayweather but I hope it's
the one recited I decided to leave and
not stake it's a two day difference from
what I can travel and it might not be it
might be amazing or who knows he may not
be a spectacle regardless I know but any
clips was only a couple of minutes and
right and look how great that was that's
true it's a shared event that
everybody's gonna be talking about and
you watch it with friends I only clips
of Mayweather's fist into McGregor his
face
I don't know I'm gonna watch it on I'm
gonna watch it on [__] my computer
screen not the same but I'll be
somewhere I really wanted a boy are you
watching things on a computer I will be
extended it's a great fight he's like a
Rocky fight it just lasts that long does
that many punches they're just bleeding
and swollen and Wow
Jim is trying to get through his his his
Iceland wife I just yelling at someone I
would be upset just Jimmy losing is
another life all right we're sorry
should go look at the lagoon yeah it's
gonna be like 5:00 in the morning no
one's gonna be able to fix them oh yeah
W one guy at the desk who's the
overnight guy going like get it fixed
tomorrow dude there's a hole tomorrow
cuz it's like these trees and pathways
on the boat oh yeah there's a whole
thing like my God's gonna tell Central
Park they called Central Park down there
and and you walk through and yeah it
looks like you're in a little park and
then and then there are shops and
restaurants
Travis along the sides if Jim went on
the backlot tour Universal Studios do
you think it would blow his mind now
this is what's called a facade as we
drive around back you might recognize
this house as the cleavers from Leave It
to Beaver than this crackling music in
an earthquake and a waterfall but it was
effects it was fake
that ship looks [__] amazing it
really is look fun yeah I
I've been thinking about a cruise for a
while and now I think I want to do it
what are you gonna do it I don't know I
have to figure out when we're off and
you know yeah I'm doing Iceland I don't
I don't regret going to Iceland I'm fine
doing that yeah we match next time
there's a big event it's a shared
experience yeah how long do you go for a
week a week is great a week as long as
anything a week now a week is good and
then you will you stop off at some of
the islands and stuff so you're you're
off the boat on the beach for a little
while you could do some scuba diving or
snorkeling or jet skis all that [__] and
then and then you get back to the boat
and how long how long were you off for
what do you mean like a way at sea how
long do you like to get up in an island
how long oh it varies sometimes it's
from like maybe 9:00 in the morning
until 3:00 in the afternoon and
sometimes it's a shorter it all depends
what we put on they get back that boat
[__] leaves happy they tell everyone
yeah it happens all the time and they
tell people you you must get back to the
boat but do you think it does leave
people once in a while oh yeah I've been
on cruises where they've left people I
hope Jim gets left and it becomes like
that movie the green inferno oh [__]
that's that one where the people where
they get eaten up get eaten yeah the
natives
yeah the natives the cannibal natives
yeah it's like his time zones wrong and
he thinks he's still got another hour
I'd be so happy see that would been
where than the girl that Jim brought
with him on the cruise finds out what
not a man he is they have to survive on
the islands together that would be the
time though to know when there's gonna
be an eclipse and if you're lucky you
could just tell those people you [__]
with me I swear I'll make this Sun go
away and it goes away see I know you're
gonna leave me alone I'll make you come
back you could be a king you got to talk
fast up like two minutes to really put
the fear of God in them yeah and then
because it's gonna come back talking
like your [__] yes yeah yeah you
gotta talk and click some point a lot
that's me I'm doing this I know this
right now is that your room on the ship
there oh yes it is oh my god you don't
you know I do not have the
seems a unnecessary but that looks like
your room yeah yeah yeah two floors the
bedroom oh my god it was beautiful he's
living like a li Zheng Oh Walt the whole
wall was just glass looking out onto
like that the whole wall oh my [__]
god
they got series - yeah the lower class
they're a bunch of Irish down there and
they dance with each other that's where
I'll be
yeah yeah keep my pants up - don't fit
right with a spender yeah well the rich
people are drinking cognac and smoking
cigars
yeah and beating their fiancees that's
right you really do become Billy Zane
every time you get on one of those boat
Billy in Zane let me tell you that's
right any Travis do you have Travis
House audio for us I think what do you
want really come back
mmm any foods out here Oh audio of what
I think it's like coming up right now
okay we don't have to it's up to you
it's your show wait a minute we should
we should explain that one of the big
reasons that Anthony @ku Mia is here we
should plug in the big announcement was
made yesterday the co-host announcement
yes coming to compound media on
September 5th September 5th that's the
day after Labor Day
yes when we come back from a vacay is
the all-new a a show yes love that name
that's such a good name is great and
that the artwork for it I love [__]
going everything and yes it's Artie
Lange yes Artie and Anthony and that's
because it rolls off the tongue
it sounds perfect dude it sounds perfect
I just like that you found somebody
that's gonna keep you on the straight
and narrow
yes yeah so it's really gonna help you
both look after each other
oh boy now this is great really good and
you guys are very funny together yeah
very funny it's very the chemistry is
really good it's very easy talking
absolutely great Artie's confer Artie is
[__] had and been on a few popular
shows right you know so I have no
worries that and either of us will will
be at a loss of words you know I
wouldn't think so he's had a lot of life
experiences
so I you know he's got he's got a lot to
talk about and and he is just one of the
funniest guys man how did this all come
about ah dude are you laying become the
guy well after a few times of him doing
my show and my doing his show we just
kind of realized that we could do you
know broadcast together and it was it
was pretty good so any luck in that in
that internet podcast space yeah yeah
and he was doing his from his house and
you know I had all the the facility set
up and everything so uh we thought it
was a pretty natural thing to just take
you know two of the guys that have been
a part of two of the biggest shows
that's right on radio why not put them
together both fires neither company
right yeah yes both their stuff that
happened not in the room right yeah both
having been incarcerated Hey at some
point our mug shots are on a on two
billboards right now one outside the
Lincoln Tunnel in New York and one on
the Jersey Turnpike that is such a great
billboard that's amazing really you
would have to look at that you would
drive by there and go what is am I
supposed to be looking for these two did
they do something I would think yeah
what is this is it's like upstate New
York you said one of them doesn't have a
giant dick and the two guys are [__]
Tilley
[Laughter]
that's awesome you legit put up
billboards yeah yeah that's so cool it's
great keith was able to swing like keith
talked to billboard company into giving
us billboards for a week let because no
one had him booked so he goes where do
you have billboards that aren't but he
he like all of a sudden came up with the
Priceline hold the whole Priceline
strategy for billboards right and said
all right these billboards cost a lot of
[__] money
but do you make anything on him when
there's nothing on there no well let me
know where your vacant billboards are
that you don't have booked I will buy it
for pennies on the dollar for a week and
for a week yeah that's what
they can be billboards outside the
Lincoln Tunnel I know if I'd made that
phone call there but no so they're all
booked until June thank you
yeah Keith is very persuasive he is put
it that way he just knows how to weigh
and he's looking into other billboards
across the country right oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah he'll do the same thing in
some other you know state some other
land that's great do good for you yeah
it's really I'm the great I'm really
psyched about this the great thing about
the a a show is that nobody technically
has top billing
I didn't think it was a big deal but
then as of like last week I think
serious is just like this is the Jim
Norton and jason Ellis Channel
oh is it yeah if I mean if you turn on
the app yeah they don't they don't
mention Sam at all no no I mean it is it
I wrote an email suggesting they do that
I was kidding check it out finally a
serious does something right right so I
see it's a Jim and Sam show on faction
talk [__] they have a picture of me and
Jason which I don't know if it is odd
because it says Jim and Sam yeah that
makes no sense right right
so you guys did it right is what I'm
saying I feel like when the hell did Sam
turn into a giant homo that's Jim it's
just an odd piece of artwork right yeah
I think it's it's still fraction talk
though stupid decision yes it is they
can have me and Sam and they could have
day out of Jason for his show to you no
no what you can't do that well I like
the same page yeah it's gotta be one
background that stays that doesn't
change with the show and that doesn't
happen on other channels either it's one
specific but I gotta put the big
celebrities look at my cool name up
there yeah they're nice yeah yeah
psyched yeah but I'm very I'm excited to
see what happens with the a a show I'm
very excited very very very excited
about how this whole thing how do you
feel about transit are you happy to be
transitioning out of transition
I knew I should have signed with you
I did I did the three years yeah as a
solo show you know I'd for the most part
have guests but there was some solo
shows sure that I had done quite a few
as a matter of fact so you know after
three years right from the start people
were saying like oh why don't you get a
guest host get this guy that guy but III
don't mind doing shows alone but I don't
have to and with somebody like Artie it
is kind of nice that I can do show alone
just in case 46 is a good time I was
thinking that yesterday I was like
jealous of the schedule oh my god damn
it [__] eight hours a week only
reason I picked those hours it was for
convenience I didn't do any kind of
research when people would want to
listen what I was like I can absolutely
be up and at work at 4:00 p.m. and they
can also play really pushed myself they
can really play it in the morning - I
mean it's not what do you play in the
mornings or replan demanding what's
right
Gavin does his show at like 10:30 is
that what I'm Gavin starts yeah here's
the thing that's great about the
compound media is there you subscribe
yeah based on how great these shows are
if they listen or not it's crime man you
know the way this works doesn't matter
yeah I could have I think up I kissed
people like I download your podcast but
I don't always listen I go it doesn't
matter just download it how many how
many podcasts are you have on your phone
that downloaded like a hundred of them
and you've never heard the show great
who cares you download yeah I I look for
quality right I and shows that fit the
platform right because people all the
time they're sending recordings of their
show and saying can I please be on your
channel for like nothing they want no
money and I'm like no we we pay our
people because they're good right and
they're entertaining so we could fill it
up 24 hours a day 7 days a week
programming but that would you know suck
oh yeah
who else you have on the network you
have yourself an already obviously Kevin
Brennan yes Kevin Brennan who does a
show called burning bridges because that
[__] it's the best
he he can get anyone mad at him yeah and
just destroy relate to
Aaron and Gino Visconti and Arenberg
they do in hot water and it's a show
that even I sometimes have to distance
myself from because they are way they
are taking this complete and total
freedom to a whole new level
I mean yet the gorilla suits things like
that bit much it is a bit icy but you
know everyone whatever you want to do
inside Dave Eastside Dave McDonald you
might remember from the Sam and Dave
schember back when young Sam Roberts yep
was young Sam Roberts now he's not
anymore ha now we all get a little older
we do like bunny Tyler yeah and you
grind uh I like Michael malice Michael
malice please like I'm out I don't know
I was very very good
he sounds mean-spirited no he's actually
very nice he does a very very
politically oriented show but he
discusses things he's been expert on
North Korea and wrote a book about noise
yeah he's been all over the place I I
read it yeah he was born in Russia right
yeah but but he he's very interesting
take on a lot of things he's he's an
extreme libertarian to the point where
he wants nothing he wants no government
no but he he comes up with these excites
I said the same thing to him I'm like
who's gonna who's gonna like make the
streets safe right for people we don't
we need a police force or something goes
private private police for your
community pays you get a private police
he goes how do you when do you feel
safer when you're in an alley or when
you're in a hotel lobby though to lobby
has security it once indoors runs
outdoors well even on the when do you
feel safe or in a hotel lobby or a
police station I know he's he's got some
holes in his story yeah I can't even
he's like one of those just crazy
sure sure libertarian guys but a very
interesting it's so good it's a good
time
now media join up I'm glad I already
have a membership but you are already in
Anthony that's such a great show I did
it yesterday just to be there for the
announcement and just you guys talking
together is so good man it's it's gonna
be a lot of fun starts September 5th at
compound Mediacom yes let's take let's
see let's eat our breakfast and Jim
Norton my tour kneeling room only
tickets are on sale now everywhere go to
Jim Norton calm I start in Seattle I a
Portland San Francisco a whole bunch of
places and the new chip podcast is up
and running with Anthony and Sam rural
and I'll be on the the Tom shaloo radio
show today yeah
5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time on Fox
News Radio cool are you doing chip
tonight I am I will be doing the newest
edition of the chips are you busy
come on you're not busy 7:30 oh no cuz I
gotta do Tom's show so I'm saying and
then I'm doing Ron Bennington's
uh that's supposed to be a surprise Ron
bankin and me are hanging out later what
time he done with him nine cool you know
how I know it's a surprise boy how you
hanging out with us to highlight where
I'm just gonna be chilling yeah so I'm
doing the chipper podcast and then
heading right over there too yeah you
start the big one yeah exactly
cool you guys have fun your new friend
we're all going to Iceland together I
can't I couldn't even go home after this
I'm taking my [__] luggage and going
right to the airport take me to a lagoon
you think that's cool Troy sure it's not
that cool is it
oh I just don't seem to be fine he's
disappointed I know yeah I don't blame
them but I was talking a bill burr he's
like don't you gotta go
[Laughter]
what is this song this is a song I by
the Smashing Pumpkins fall 1979 I've
heard I don't I hate the Smashing
Pumpkins why I just never liked their
music there was so much better stuff out
there during the time they were really
big butterfly wings no I never liked his
voice yeah I don't terrible zero is
great yeah no it's not I don't know all
right tonight tonight
that's another college that record that
records on the best records of the 90s
oh stop it man calling the infinite sad
yes love it a hundred love it leave I
didn't like dying these music I think
that was the problem
here's some CNN nine good network
[Laughter]
there's just there's some they're doing
that 90s like docu-series yes CNN and
they did just music last week it's just
here's the last great decade of music
did they do they bring up how Trump
destroyed everything good in music yep
yeah the 90s CNN they found a wiggle
that in I didn't like the 90s music it
was just so eclectic and so yeah there
was actual like genres and reasons for
different radio stations wow people were
actually creating music you know what I
mean like actually taking chances and
doing things a little bit of that one
big storm by that I'll say what's the
look today is pretty good today
okay yeah which we should have known the
whole albums yeah yeah uh Siamese Dream
yeah you like the Smashing Pumpkins
Smashing Pumpkins I like the Smashing
Pumpkins terrible yeah I saw I even saw
that once with Chili Peppers in Pearl
Jam and I said uh who's Smashing
Pumpkins these guys are going nowhere
did
was here before Billy shaved his head oh
yeah when you had that leggy a comb-over
in the yeah Don yeah I've heard all
these song did not fan it was just you
know these are like every song from the
90's yeah been a 90s indie movie some
90s indie movie every song kind of
sounds like reality bites they all fit
in reality bites exactly but I get why
you wouldn't like 90s music because like
a lot of people who came from Sabbath
and kiss and stuff like that didn't like
90s music microaggression called you old
right there by the way oh no because
liking nineties music is you know
microaggression oh and me don't like
that's a micronation I pretty eclectic
taste in music I just I think the 90s
was just a sound I didn't love like I
didn't love Nirvana some of this stuff
is really great yeah I was never a huge
navona fit that's something I will say
it was an amazing whole thing Nirvana
and yeah I loved Soundgarden of course
though I didn't like them I like a
couple of those songs I like I never big
Soundgarden No oh okay
no it I think that's who you ask hey um
do you think who's better Smashing
Pumpkins there Sean Paul oh God see
every dirty Rock I can love I love Sean
Paul yeah God do you ever need any rock
a little dirty rock how about yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah have a little
temperature Sean Paul it's nice busy is
very good I'm still in love with you is
very good what a man gotta do what a man
I'm not gonna pretend I'm not familiar
with Sean Paul's cattle apparently yeah
he's very good
I mean bad thing
in every club it's a good bar service
that's in every club I know yeah I can't
say that I prefer Sean Paul to snow I do
it was pretty good yeah island jamming
sometimes right yeah okay if I have a
coconut drink someone of questionable
ethnicity is bringing me my drink sure
something like that yeah I like Sean
Paul on my ex-girlfriend turned down man
you're like this is good [__] no I did
hated it at first
at first and then he gave it a chance
the Spanish extra song he has on [__]
one of his albums is so good yeah he's
the Spanish version if I'm still in love
with you you ever hang out and damaged
no not that ones though huh
you ever hang out and dance halls no I
don't my ranks no fatty Arbuckle's
dance dance hall with a coke bottle this
is great get busy is good how about a
little get busy for [__] sake I'm not
telling
oh okay yeah he says he says get busy
what sometimes yeah ice cream sick
that's it I like this a lot that you do
monotonous yeah yeah we got off a plane
show me his iPhone
it's just think he's been listening to
Sean Paul for a half-hour I love it yeah
they could be monotonous it was just
meant for for dancing right like once
once that beat starts you're just
dancing you don't care what the words
are right that it repeats the words
eight hundred [__] times yeah yeah
you get new moving on - I like that beat
ya [__]
oh oh it's good it's good right Anthony
yeah what's your talking about pot
[__] [__] yeah yeah my sex that's
awesome sex drugs rock and roll - rum
drinking rum drinking rum yeah you like
that [__] that's cool it's about banging
chicks yeah I do yeah but I like I don't
like music
what about 90s like hip-hop some of it's
okay I like older hip-hop in there I
like Godfather's Hades hip-hop is pretty
goddamn funny something yeah yeah well
my name is yeah it's very it's very
upbeat and and if you watch the videos
of it and everything very colorful and I
don't mean that as a joke yeah it's very
colorful because I insist the 80s are
the 80s people's interpretation what
they thought the future was supposed to
look like
so yeah if it's fully dressed like they
thought they were supposed to dress cuz
the 80s is the future right there in it
going like what do we do it's the future
and you go okay let's just kind of wacky
right and it just now looks really silly
insane because we're always wearing
shirts and stuff yep The Fat Boys were
funny
I loved funny [__] rap even the
gangster rap [__] was hilariously funny
where they say like the message is the
credit that has been like the first
gangsta rap song but it's as by really
fun it's like a jungle sometimes I keep
from going on yeah whose kid Creole in
that group I think he was I think so
yeah oh boy he's in Dutch oh yes oh he
stamped some guys probably hitting on
him or something a homeless guy he
thought he was hitting Doherty was hit
look the guy said dot hey so what's up
well he was like one of those I stepped
it up
I need love LL Cool J Oh money yeah this
time I'm considering dad's [__] buns
off you are those buns are moving Jim is
really shaking his buns in here Jim what
shakin those what an awful word so Ram
my word did you did Chris Christie try
to become your co-host uh no he was
trying to wheel in there at the fan well
he decided I don't know just like he
decided not to move to Washington DC he
decided to take himself out of the
running
oh really to be the replacement for my
friends the governor of New Jersey and
he's like being he's is that the the
radio stations yeah he's just too much
controversy yeah interestingly enough
like right before he decided to take
himself out of the running
yeah the station decided to take him out
of the running right yeah and then he
decided that no no no I'd rather not
do this do you think he got right in the
station managers face it was like you
got a problem
what's that tough guy yeah you did that
oh you're real tough guy you're real
tough guy yeah with his giant thing of
not yeah oh not one crumb no no one drop
a cheese came that was so embarrassed
that was embarrassing and I cool you
cannot if you're a fat guy like that you
best just go back to your [__] seat
all this queso was in intent yeah oh
yeah you know I mean sitting like the
owners box box yeah yeah but yeah so he
was he was obviously doing Phil in shows
on the fan here in New York as he was
also the Governor of New Jersey which he
still is yeah people tend to forget that
yeah yeah well I'm done how much time
does he have left and his governorship
November yeah he's out like in November
this year yeah but he was it look like
he's pretty much who's a contender for
that gig no fur governor of [__]
they've had some winners over there that
corazon guy who wrapped up his vehicle
on the right he wasn't
no I think no he was driving it was one
of the staties we're driving him but he
was also involved in all kinds of
misappropriation of funds [__] was he
yeah and then there was of course we
remember the gay governor I am I am a
gay and proud gay American white yeah
looked over at him like what she stood
there with a knife just cutting
bratwurst I really maybe someone should
have told her before that big
announcement yes he looked very
surprised and then you know then the
crystal Todd Whitman [__] yes Chrissy
Todd Whitman who gave Howard Stern rest
stop on the Jersey Turnpike much too
many people's chagrin yes she did I only
know her cuz she was at SummerSlam one
year to Governor Jim Florio was one of
my earliest jokes was about our governor
Jim Florio actually pretty good joke
yeah better what is it was it as good as
give him a touching joke oh that one
that joke still haunts me touching
myself Andy Kaufman yes terrible so know
that my Jim Florio joke was it would
kill I was like Gus I forget how I set
it up I was like I'm my haircut I did a
bad joke about my haircut and then I
said something about I met Janet
O'Connor we stood side-by-side we look
like testicles and I said think governor
Florio was there that night and he came
over and stood right between us she was
calling him a dick oh my god I could see
if he's an office that's going over bail
my god um run City then you go into your
Watergate material it's weird nobody a
while ago see I mean he was just a time
pack because nobody laughed in here I
know now the travesty the Joker did try
had you heard that joke before first
time did you think that was a joke yeah
didn't work for me but I don't know
maybe it on the road not laugh yeah on
the road I guess it like outside of
Jersey he's lost look look look at
monkey
that's that show the the British office
is has such rewatchable
yeah you could just throw one episode on
and it is hilarious to watch it's the
fun of funniest things oh yeah yeah what
a great character just a buffoon I love
finchy
how much he then you finally meet him
and he's just an [__] yeah can't
stand him no the one of the best
dynamics what was anybody that was had a
good relationship with the guy that came
over from the other place Neil Neil yeah
because even finchy and Neil are talking
and David's just an outcast can't get
can't get in there yeah so he just
laughs too hard at what Finch he's
saying it's such cringe oh love it yes I
always mentioned the relationship I mean
you know hate me inhales yeah yeah a
couple of points talking about how drunk
they got the night before it's so funny
and one of them it's the first one of
the second season with having the party
and he's like yes if I drank yes if I
drink and the guy in the office goes he
drinks I enjoyed the Netflix movie the
David Brent movie yeah oh yes very much
because right the like on the road life
on the time was him trying to like be
cool with his bandmates that were just
hired musicians
yeah and they they wanted nothing to do
they did not really like him no they
really great soundtrack to that was sad
I loved it Wow I listened to all the
time [__] it's just such a funny concept
the slough concept for a song cuz it's
just there's nothing going on in the
town there's no reason for the song to
exist the beginning of the show when
they show that rotary in Slough and the
side of the building it's one of the
most depressing show openers yeah yeah
has ever been made yeah it just tells
you everything you need to know about
this working environment yeah there's
not a touch of sunshine coming through
it's just completely drab and rainy yeah
and and you just look and go oh my god
if I had to work there this is life this
is people's life yes the lyrics are so
brilliant though because they're not
like they don't smash you over the head
with a hammer but they're completely
somebody trying to write like
a rock star like their there's no
personal connection to any of it it's
just they're all just trying to sound
cool yeah you know and they just don't
quite get there subway has a new floor
he's singing over the subway floor yeah
it's really I love that I lady gypsy did
you saw the video for Lady gypsy
masterpiece that [__] highway oh yes
so bad he points to the lady gypsy when
he says ladyship she's standing there
the jesters journey is done watch on
doesn't fit with the time period at all
they're trying to portray the face he
makes me uh it's it's so good who never
he never ceases to entertain me no it's
great
yeah the character is amazing area all
the eighteen summers he's [__] 43 but
but it's what an absolute ass would
think a rock so yeah but he thinks he's
super sexy though peachy from around a
tree yeah yeah look at the way he's
looking into the camera it's so bad so
bad and he's literally doing everything
that he's describing in the song yeah
pointing ladies in the water watching
her dance is [__] terrible joke gypsy
does it dance
that's sunlight on her it's so [__]
bad you don't think that he found
somebody that could do a real gypsy
dance I don't know if she can or not but
he would heat it was such a great video
and probably its own Avett brent didn't
find a woman oh no no no no her gypsy do
ya know his [__] gut and tits it's
amazing he's walking through that I know
man tits are hilarious he went down and
he went down in the Heather but there's
just enough Heather just to cover him
for the song
like she's just in the [__] woods by
her Heather right silly it's just
literal everything's right well yeah and
yes the part that she says even though
he's singing it she's lip-syncing it
because she's saying yeah selling and
it's branch look at the tree branch like
a dick it's so stupid
my favorite face ever I know he doesn't
after the guitar solo which is really a
piano solo yeah yeah throughout the
series like all the glances to the
camera are like he has this connection
with the audience
yeah but the audience is completely with
the rest of the characters not with him
we're not smiling back yeah exactly
that's great her dance rules all right
hands on his hips pointing hey Travis
this has been a couple of important
pieces of audio we should listen to
since you've been gone of course the my
head can't take it Dan in it what's that
I thinking Kelly Clarkson but oh no um
what was that rainbow or something I
don't I like Street of Dreams oh yeah
that's
that great song yeah but oh yeah where
as there used to be just a single show
and then some little things mattered
about on this channel there's now a
full-time live lineup on the channel we
all share our a space here love it and
there is a menace who's been calling and
disrupting radio shows lately that we
want to shame you know we don't think
you should be doing it and that's why if
we think if we hear this person calling
any of the radio shows on this channel
be convene and rich Oh Nick DiPaolo
we're going we're going to play the
clips on the air the shame the shame
this you stop doing
somebody named Edgar keeps calling me Oh
interesting she's disrupting what are
the odds names to have I know and these
guys are just trying to trying to do
their radio shows no and and somebody
named Edgar is being disruptive and
we're we're here to shame it that's why
if you do this
yeah we'll play it on the air to shame
you'll plan yeah just to shame of course
yes let's play that Trevor's Jimmy I
don't believe that Jimmy good why do you
play the first two notes I hit the wrong
your character you're doing a good
another guy's character new time he's
calling up he's doing a Norton character
no oh my god that's disruptive don't do
that again
yeah please don't it don't do that it
was funny though yeah that's any more
calls yes somebody else called in oh no
no no no this is the phone call just to
give a contact sure so Billy in Los
Angeles has been on the phone for our
bill how are you stuck in traffic your
thoughts I don't know maybe you're on
foot somewhere pulling down a statute
had a chance to think about it I could
think of three overt black racist good
camo Cambon the Dallas shooter and that
[__] dead [__] if you would have
taken better better care of himself
Patricio who [__] wish you would have
taken care of himself I know
funniest one of the funniest men alive
and in song song yeah I like to go who's
the guy with Nick that really has no
clue I don't know do we know anything
that's Andy Oh Andy Dufresne and do
thing I ll t ET le Y built Italy oh
right the Y yeah forgot the Y no not at
all man all these disruptions though
it's alright yeah it's not right
yeah a guy shouldn't do that stuff it's
disruptive to the other show ya know and
especially I mean Covino and rich they
got upset when Edgar called them oh
really
and they said that the Edgar call had
ruined 45 minutes of radio yeah what how
do you do that I don't know I guess they
were on a roll and then Edgar call it
just really put the brakes on everything
yeah I could see that you're doing that
but I can't see that destroying 45
minutes of your show no I can't either
but yeah apparently it did uh-huh I'll
take their word for it so don't do that
anymore no more do you know who that is
calling yeah no no do you know oh yeah
no no no we have no idea it was a
goddamn good Edgar do you this [__]
waiter telling a JDC couple the
restaurant they couldn't share a
restaurant cuz I they couldn't share a
dessert cuz it didn't look right
good what was it a [__] that might not
look right one [__] two mouths they
wanted a dessert ice cream sundae
together yeah with two spoons and the
waiter goes today bring two separate
dishes he said it wouldn't look right
with two gentlemen eating out of the
same sundae it doesn't go with the
ambiance of the
restaurant huh hmm they said they fired
the waiter yeah they should've oh my
goodness yeah you can't [__] it's not
even the owner it was just a waiter wait
I who would give a [__] if [__] a guy
comes in with a dog and wants to share a
[__] desert like if you're just a
waiter working there mind your own
beeswax
yeah who could possibly care oh I don't
care two guys are eating a dessert oh I
bet you don't know maybe because they
were putting their own topping on it
that don't look right what you think the
top it was gone my people are [__]
nervy aren't they like oh the waiter
really are there's a [__] some people
want to bring their morality into a lot
of [__] watch the chagrin of other
people's rights oh just stop yes of two
men are having a Sunday right